Remember Sarah Palin that kooky chick
from alaska
while she wrote a piece on breitbart.com
yesterday that's where I get all
my news
I and basically calling for the
impeachment of President Obama we got a
little snippet Korea
President Obama's rewarding the
lawlessness including his own is the
foundational problem here
it's not going to get better and in fact
irreparable harm can be done
in this lame duck term as he continues
to make up his own laws
as he goes along and mark my words will
next medal in the US Court system with
appointments that will forever change
the basic interpretation about
constitutions roles
in protecting our rights okay so I she's
talking about a lot of things if you
read the whole article and willing to it
below she's talking about
somebody immigration stuff she's talking
about to selecting the Obamacare laws
that is going to enforce
and a whole slew of other things in
court appointment an executive actions
it cetera
it cetera as a before we get to the
specific and should
anyone on earth paid any attention
two-way Miss Sarah Palin say no but I
mean bitch
clearly she has a form yeah and you know
when I was reading this piece
on my part I comfortable even open the
web yeah I'm sorry that of my fun yeah I
apologize
then they have you left the virus yes
I'll on
but can you imagine if wanna have your
you know hollywood friends had seen you
select looking over his shoulder in a
hollywood 90
a good she's a cartel on a mission to
protect us but that we have to remember
yeah our people Yahoo he her word
and neck that's a staggering name really
be a you know that she she does whole
wat how much weight do you think
she actually hold because they do agree
with that we can make fun of her body
obviously there's some percentage
that I really dig this woman I think
that she's still an important figure for
a lot of americans and i mean clearly
we're talking about her and she's got
this forum on wherever she wants to
write a piece like that she can
she gonna bring it on the Huffington
Post I'm sure they were published as
well and so
I mean it's just it's it's scary you
know she talks about that
she's afraid that Obama's gonna meddle
in the US Court I hope email
yeah we use mean it has to take the
United
going down leah is already being
obliterated for
the last week when with that Hobby Lobby
you know decision the horses left the
barn on that one
yeah so all he tall hump Obama condemn I
think but of course people the label me
as a crazy liberal
well I think he can do with is start to
repair it
yeah and of course both side only care
about activist judges when they do
things that they don't like nobody
really seems that any principle or
consistency
i doing when they do I correct that then
somehow that out the window
bomb white like you would get rid of her
though so I get it there's a certain
amount of people that like a whitish
like I just heard this week she may host
the view black shemale did not claim a
loss that era and the
been hurt to have a car they are now in
Akron Ohio now you know
higher know she do it I think shoot I'll
share with you
she felt she is a whore right good
people she is i mean jobs not not a
fucking horrible anybody that he or she
is a mediocre will do anything
so do you think when they tell you can
use language yeah I'm right outside
review work there %uh me
that wanna benefit to being the third
time guest you're allowed the starters
from any way I will add to the point
where the person you are not allowed
your I just think that way when where
and when when she's out there talking
about immigration it's hard to take
anybody from alaska seriously when I
attack on immigration like
if we carry warning about immigration at
least you go yeah well you understand
something about taxes I'm sure in Texas
but
she's like me what it with the russians
are integrating into alaska it's very
unfair
somebody who can fill and I mean you can
be a person who have anywhere in
understanding
the I mean I'm sorry I can hit I think
that these are parent
be converted for anything for the
reminder of the first time anyone has
ever said anything nice about Rick Perry
go ahead both pro
reconquer yeah did you know that he
refused the request
thank you Obama's hand yeah they were
gonna meet on the tarmac and I refuse to
do it he wanted to take a private
meeting in a bombing in line do that so
they but he still walked out on the
tarmac
to see her in the morning I just knew he
wouldn't even you hasn't gone anywhere
we don't get off your JetBlue to have
okay so do you think
any love these things like the executive
we talk a lot about the executive
actions on the show that
they're giving him no choice cuz they
won't the congress will give him life
hands on a given no choice but again I
still do believe in separation of powers
I think both sides are being
sorted disingenuous hear something I am
is there any obvious that you don't like
that he's doing
any of this stuff the executive actions
any other okay personally I really think
he's over a barrel here
I mean I really don't think they've
given any with whom they don't work with
him
yeah so what he's supposed to do so you
don't mind the executive action thing
which we both talk about how we did
he's now are less than even George that
anyway honest if he were not
someone who's actions in the years I
agreed with I probably would take
defense
you know I have to be honest right that
but in my case here
when we're dealing with a congress that
is ridiculous
and completely just block any kinda
move to make progress what is he
supposed to do yeah I'm good he said
that cuz that's what I've been saying
every week that whether I'm
believe if it with the other guy who was
a Republican taking all these executive
actions people would be going crazy
I have is ABC would be going not so we
still have to be aware
yeah I know it is less and you know that
present before but I mean yeah
for me Obama could have by kinda
fought harder to protect the environment
and and and regulations I know that he
was
I a pic a former barrel with it but
that's been disappointing about
here at mister majority for certain
about it the Act nine months or
something like that
filed on it is it in retrospect now
crazy to think that bill clinton
was impeached or almost injured with the
technically in PJs they are going to put
out there was a blow job as a doctor he
was in pain when
but not yeah United like in retrospect
isn't that crazy considering it was
really about a blowjob in the word is
yeah micro it was it was it was
embarrassing you guys in which I S
it was stupid it was stupid and the way
I mean
I've nothin on really care what you know
other people think about us
yeah but but the way we look to the
world my cell in teheran like
going would have been nice if we look
that way in the world again like america
again they're blowjob like that it seems
like the good old days turning right
compared to everything they think about
now
right the nineties the last great tech
and ETA I'm getting really why should
get a t-shirt really and it just says
not my president
are yo as far as like Bush right but not
now
Raena know you could lead to
saying exactly ideally a lot and relax
about the love thing that I would have
to do that
traveling abroad on but which are
difficult yes
but you know when he was a random people
were complaining
I really with this is like I hope this
is not who I wanted this is
he does not represent bush yeah he does
not represent me
yeah and that you know then again a lot
any Italian colony it's cuz I think they
are
will say the same thing about Obama that
they he does represent them
yeah well I guess that's why we both men
have two people had a guy i no matter
what
yeah